[Musique]
non
je m'appelle télé le démarrer sabourin
j'ai 11 ans et je suis en 6e année
académique ali j'aime apprendre les
mathématiques et l'anglais
j'adore voyager pour découvrir le monde
je suis très sportif et le cheerleading
est un sport qui me passionne c'est pour
cela que dans ma présentation j'ai
décidé de vous parler de la mer du
cheerleading aux jeux olympiques saviez
vous que dans les années 1800 c'étaient
les jeunes qui pratiquent le
cheerleading
c'est assez surprenant en fait le tube
dean a commencé en 1869 dans une
université américaine située au lieu de
josé c'est thomas petit bleu qui avait
au début l'idée de vouloir canaliser
l'énergie de la foule pour mieux
encourager les footballeur mais c'est en
1923 qu'on aperçoit les premières femme
chérie 2
cela a pris 40 ans et qu'elles soient
majoritaires en 1930 nous apercevons les
premiers pop
il était alors fait de papier crépon
mais à cause du mouvement breuses que
faisait les tories 2 et des mots va être
conditions les ont changé en 1960 pour
des propos plus résistant en vinyle
c'est en 1973 que le cheerleading est
devenu un vrai ce pas ce qui veut dire
que ce n'était plus qu'un simple à tous
au foot barre mais bien se propose pas
cela consiste et un chorégraphies
rythmées sur de la musique quand on ya
ajouté des levées des sceaux et de la
jeunesse et c'est en 1982 qu'on aperçoit
la première qu'options nationale de
rugby
aux etats unis cette année ou juste d'un
épique de tien giang 2008
il y a eu des représentations de
cheerleading si le canada les etats-unis
la norvège la russie l'allemagne la
suisse et les pays-bas qui ont fait du
tri des auges de répit à la prison money
de clôture ya une petite commission
amical si les flyers l'équipe de morial
qui ont représenté le canada aux jeux
olympiques
les actes
était très stressée à l'idée de devoir
vous sentez tout le canada mais il était
très contente pour le shopping car c'est
un grand pas vers l'avenir de ce sport
le comité international olympique depuis
2005 25 mille dollars au cheerleading
mieux avancer concrétiser ce sport c'est
en 2019 qui vont prendre les grandes
décisions si le cheerleading devait un
jour un style olympique
ici le devient sus aux jeux olympiques
d'été de 2024 situé à paris qui vaille
amis comme une vraie discipline à l'épée
je crois que c'est très possible que le
top 10 9e
un jour une spirale un pétard à tokyo en
2020 il va avoir plusieurs nouvelles
disciplines olympiques comme le surf la
planche à roulettes le karaté le sauvant
le base-ball email escalade et plusieurs
d'entre eux ont déjà été en sport de
démonstration tout comme et holding pour
finir tout est possible que le taux
reading devienne un jour il un pays il
se serait un rêve d'aller un jour en
tant qu'athlète car je pratique ce sport
depuis que je suis toute petite
il s'est vraiment ma passion et si on
fait le calcul en 2020 tag ne ré
exactement 18 ans si l'âge parfait pour
y aller et maintenant croyez vous que le
cheerleading devra un jour nos lacs et
moi j'en suis convaincu
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]